[Music]
just over the past few years
there have been enormous advances in
data analytic
capabilities the advances in the tools
are enormous but most of the energy is
on the open source
side of thing commercial software
development is of course constrained by
the amount of resources that any
individual company can
put into them whereas on the open source
side
there's just the entire community
contributes
to development of of new capabilities
and new tools
in addition to a lot of uh professional
support from
the big tech companies for open source
which is growing
by the day so you get access to really
cutting-edge analytical tools
because you use open source
the other interesting thing is that you
get access in the open source community
to tools and capabilities developed in
other domains
whatever domain you are in maybe it's
environmental sciences
or healthcare you can get access to
tools and packages that were developed
for financial services
or vice versa and you see that kind of
cross-fermentation
really uh power the
open source uh communities many of the
most widely used and powerful analytical
packages work across
multiple languages tensorflow is a is a
good example
that is a powerful machine learning
framework that was developed by google
it's
uh open source and it's uh available in
all of the major open source languages
r and and python to name the the two
main ones
so people can use the tools they like to
achieve the results in the languages
they like
uh knowing that there's consistency uh
in terms of the underlying uh
algorithms and operation of all these
packages
finally code-based analytics make it
easy to see the flow
of the analysis and it's essentially
self-auditing
in highly regulated businesses like
healthcare and financial services where
i came from
this can be a lifesaver
open source is absolutely appropriate
for enterprise level data science
it's a great way to boost productivity
as it can empower
all the interested power parties in the
organization
at my company there were many people
that i as a senior manager
didn't even know about who were working
on developing projects using open source
tools so you can let a thousand flowers
bloom now importantly such freedom can
be done with
enterprise level curation you can do
this in a controlled way
now of course i t likes that because you
don't have a million people
launching different things which are
unaudited or unvalidated
but you can still have the same create
creativity of the team
tools like rstudio really help provide
this full production lifestyle cycle
within a curated environment that is
enterprise grade there are so many
people contributing
to that community there are so many
tremendous packages out there
you can be comfortable that if you're
using a commercial software that has
been
audited and vetted and has gone through
a process before it was released into
the wild
that is greater than what might happen
in the open source community
but at the same time in the open source
community the crowdsourcing
mean and the enormous number of people
that are contributing
means that the quantity of tremendous
enterprise level packages
or tools is much much larger
there are tools that can help companies
curate
audit and validate all of those tools
that are out there packages like
rstudio let you
do that and have a walled garden where
the appropriateness and quality of all
the packages
is monitored within the organization
my personal experience building support
for open source software
in an organization means starting small
what is very powerful i think are small
g
whiz demonstration product
uh you know you take take this in small
bites
projects with quick turnaround that
demonstrate value
then you're gonna have people looking
over your shoulder saying
how can i do that so you don't have to
start out with a large investment
but in my experience the power of these
tools is such that you very
quickly have people saying they want in
they want to try
to do some of this stuff themselves so
you obviously don't want the appearance
of going rogue in your organization
and rejecting i.t standards
but very quickly you will find that you
develop
it buy-in i think as the years have gone
by that's much much easier
to do i think certainly within our
organization when i first started
getting involved in this stuff
uh there wasn't a lot of it support but
by the time i left my organization
it was a major sponsor of open source
tools
because they knew that they could uh
make sure that anything that was allowed
inside the organization
did meet our quality standards
certainly not executives don't need to
know how to code to manage a data
science team i was a coder
and it did help me be a champion uh
with some credibility in the
organization but it's
absolutely not necessary and you can't
really expect that or make that a
requirement
you know the higher you go in any
organization the more you are going to
be responsible for supervising people
who are experts in their domain and know
more about
that than you do i was a ceo
and of course as most ceos do i
was promoted through a particular
business vertical
in my case investments that's what i had
expertise in
but i didn't know anything or i didn't
have any particular expertise
in sales or legals legal and certainly
not
i.t so an executive doesn't need to be
fluent in all topics and indeed cannot
be
but it helps to be conversant and some
of that is learning on the job
but adam and i to do that at a minimum
you need to be curious so you will have
lots of people who work for you who will
know things you don't and you have to be
respectful of their their knowledge
uh and you need to listen to those
people who are coming in and telling you
what needs to be done and listen with an
open mind
uh ultimately the leader has to make the
decision
but you want to make it with the best
possible input
from your teams the and being respectful
when someone says i don't think this is
a good idea but again
leadership is about making the call at
the end of the day
but you have to be very
mindful of where the expertise lies in
your organization and that applies in
all areas
of course including leading data science
teams
i got started in our about 2006 so
that's what
15 years ago i became frustrated with
the limitations of excel
i felt i had taken it as far as i could
one of the things that really bugged me
was how my current self had no idea what
my past self did
when i opened a spreadsheet from a year
or two prior
so i you know how do i remember where
the critical dependencies are across
multiple sheets what does this formula
do all of these things
became very opaque uh in
some of the really big complicated
spreadsheets that i did
i like the idea of open source tools so
i discovered and started working with
r and i started working with one toe in
the water i was moving back and forth
with excel
importing and exporting data using some
macro tools to
to manage that but as the months went on
i used excel
less and less because i got more fluent
with r
and you know found that i was getting
answers faster
and getting answers with reusable
code uh much more frequently
so i i eventually just
excel just sort of withered away and i
stopped using it
and even when i became a ceo obviously
playing around with spreadsheets or r
wasn't part of my day job
but i i like to keep my myself sharp
in terms of working with r and this had
a good corporate purpose because it
helped me be an evangelist for r
within my organization and again uh
by the time i left the company these
open source
tools were a an everyday
part of analytics across
uh just about all of the verticals in my
company
the power of these tools is so
so large and it's so easy to find
really cool examples of
what you can do with these tools it
doesn't
take very much digging and certainly if
you look at some of the
the examples in the r studio gallery you
saw you see all sorts of stuff
all sorts of g whiz little uh projects
and dashboards and tools that
for me immediately made me think wow
yeah yeah that could solve a problem i
have or that would be a great way to
present some of the information that's
specific to my domain
uh even if the the information or the
the data set
isn't relevant to to my job so it's
very easy to find things that are very
exciting
uh to to help advance
data science in any organization and you
know
it's still early going on the power of
data science in many organizations there
are many organizations even
you know very sophisticated quantitative
analytic organizations
that haven't gone after the low-hanging
fruit
that data science has
brought to fruition in the last few
years i'm speaking from experience on
this
so i you know
once the ball gets rolling it's very
easy to keep it going